hi everyone my name is Gianna and I was
in commercial endorsements so my name is
Evan and over the past eight weeks I've
been the intern in the TV scripted
department sophomore year of high school
there was a couple of upperclassmen who
told me about this career prep program
and that's how I met Evan she was in the
fashion organization at Duke and I'm in
the fashion organization at Yale and I
just thought okay maybe I'll just take a
chance and email her and ask if we might
look for housing together I took the
chance and she seemed really nice guys
are in college in this tremendous space
of growth and development you have this
super vague idea of what you want your
life to look like I mean I loved
watching entourage and just assumed
that's how the agency world works
sounds expecting to walk in like see an
art gold and haven't yet not my everyone
at CAA was amazing and super nice and
they were all welcoming so during my
time here I was able to create pitch
lists the brands like these will come to
us and be like hey we need a client who
meshes with our brand and our mission
statement who you guys have this is my
first project where I was given this
grade which is in the CIA database
detailing the exclusive contracts
between talent and studios and I
compared that to the same list but as
created by variety we do spend most of
our time at work and then we come home
and
sometimes we just veg out on the couch I
think I really like the entertainment
industry because I like the idea of
projects you finish something you create
something and then you move on to create
something else that kind of trajectory
is very unique to the entertainment
business and I think if I have to work a
little bit harder to make sure I have
that next project I'm willing to do it
because I just think it's more worth it
in terms of what I'm looking for
it's so exciting to see that like what
you're passionate about and see you
actually pursue that I think that's just
a really great opportunity for us I
think personally where I've kind of
learned to target more is to remember
that you have your own voice and you
have things to offer and then it's okay
to share that with people there are so
many more stories and that need to be
told whether it's probably about mental
health they're talking about abuse or
violence and in your family people go
through serious things even at a young
age younger than then I think we we
realize kids are ready for that I think
there is a market for it just think it
means that it just hasn't been done I
just think it's been an awesome journey
for you and I'm still only the beginning
yes thank you it has you know eight
weeks is a short amount of time but I
feel like there has been a lot of growth
through entertainment you can be an
activist and I see myself placing people
where I think they will shine and that's
what an agent does so why not it'll be
that advocate for people of color for
people telling the less voice stories I
hope that in ten years I have balance
going into the work force at this age
you dedicate yourself to your craft and
I don't mind prioritizing
but I don't want to lose myself and I
want to make sure that I spend time with
friends and family I know the effect
that I want to have I know the change I
want to make and then network then I've
been able to make at the academy gold
has like really comforted me like I know
there are people like me who are looking
out for me and also trying to do the
same thing so I don't feel alone in it I
just follow my gut know my end goal is
to affect change I'll make it there
[Music]
you